so okay I heard you're promoting during
Shark Week what's that all about
yeah you know we're just really we're
really [ __ ] Matt yeah so yeah we just
did some Shark Week promos you got to
get the shark audios they're very
passionate so you're gonna run shark
what you're gonna run promos during
Shark Week that try and get people to
watch your show yeah did you bring one
is that right did I did bring a Shark
Week promo let's take a look yes in a
star costume on television on Shark Week
dreams come true yeah how about that
Tanisha from sophomore year if you swim
past a shark why they have a sense where
they attack you
[Music]
[Applause]
you know it's great Hannibal once that
but not the money comes in you're gonna
be able to afford a better shark dog cuz
that looks like a shark a shark ate you
didn't bother to digest you you know it
was deliberate Conan I have a horrible
start costo I don't want to have a fancy
shark costume because I want people to
be able to relate to me yeah I liked it
and it was like oh I can't relate to
Hannibal look how fancy his shark
costume so I guess our customs that
regular people can get you know now you
like millionaires that drive Priuses
yeah yeah yeah cuz it's a garbage car
[Applause]